si les sourires sont toujours là c'est
que ce bus qui bascule est un outil
pédagogique
un des ateliers d'une journée de
sensibilisation ski bus et cars périer
c'est à la fois prendre conscience des
risques de la portée du risque en les
mettant en fonction de différents
ateliers en situation d'accident donc
avec des simulations des chocs à des
vitesses des ponots un car scolaire qui
se couche mais également se permettre de
se connaître soi même une quarantaine de
partenaires a été sollicité pour cette
deuxième édition pompiers médecine du
travail ou encore l'association
le port de la ceinture on la met
systématiquement ses rentrées dans notre
culture
le port de la ceinture tout le monde
même bébé ils savent à y mettre la
ceinture mais il la met mal on l'a mais
par peur du jardin par réflexe mais on
l'a même à lille c'est sympa que ça doit
être ça doit pas être dans les parties -
lille sa part qu on doit enlever les
doubles ils se croient qu'on va enlever
le téléphone portable de la proche ski
bus et les cars périer c'est lary 220
conducteur qui assure 170 service par
jour comme françoise qui transportent
des élèves depuis trois ans 14 30
quotidienne derrière un volant je vous
lance le test
malachie opticienne vous les interpréter
la façon déjà de quitter sa place d'un
façon de se comporter sur la route il ya
des petites choses comme ça quand on se
rend compte une journée dédiée aux
conducteurs de bus mais aussi les autres
salariés
74 % des accidents mortels ont lieu lors
de trajets quotidiens